you said something really interesting
and I think I've brought this up in
Prior interviews but I read an article
about how extroverts and sometimes
narcissists do much better in job
interviews versus introverts and people
that would actually be more well
qualified for the job but they don't
come across well when they present
themselves so I'm imagining that's the
same with pitches because I think a lot
of people and this is probably why
they're such great writers is they're so
internal they're so like worried about
things and thinking that they don't make
the best impression but they might
actually be the best person for the job
so it sounds like that's that's a common
thing with pitching that maybe people
that are great show people mm-hmm that
that they maybe don't have the material
as much to back it up versus the ones
that maybe they're a little more shy or
I hate to use the term mousy but you
know somebody that might be less of a
show person writers in general most of
the writers I've met are a little bit
more introverted they're used to working
by themselves that's writing is a
solitary thing unless you write with a
partner but you know it's it's kind of a
solitary thing and it's hard for them to
express everything verbally in fact I
think it's probably more terrifying for
them to be able to talk about themselves
than it is to talk about their scripts
as well and I think that's what things I
always have to tell writers is if you
don't feel comfortable in who you are
what you should do is write your own
kind of little personal story or outline
of who you are as an example one of my
favorites is I used to do the interviews
for the Disney and internship program
and there was a guy there from UCLA and
he he had the most interesting story
about himself and I said tell me a
little bit about yourself because that's
usually how a lot of us start off you
know we will ask people tell us a little
bit so they can kind of ease you into
before you doing the pitch and he was so
funny and he just said well I grew up as
a military brat and I was born and you
know Germany
and I spent you know five years there
and then I spent four years in Thailand
with my you know my dad was transferred
to Thailand and then and then I I ended
up in the Philippines and and anyway he
said Here I am now UCLA and this is my
my fifth year at UCLA and it's the
longest I've ever spent anywhere and one
time and he says but you know my
favourite thing is I can translate
anymore I can translate any movie I can
read subtitles and and he named off all
the languages that he had learned I
thought like God what an interesting guy
he he has such a beautiful worldview and
think what he can bring to his stories
about the diverse cultures about looking
at things through a different lens than
just an American lens and I then had him
you know come in and he talked to the
rest of our group and he talked about
the same kind of thing and we all loved
him and that was what nailed it for us
is that he had that kind of sensibility
about himself he wasn't afraid to just
sort of talk about himself and but he
did it in a way that made it interesting
and made us realize this guy could get
must give us a different he probably has
the ability to give us a different voice
and it's writing interesting there are
other there are other you know ideas
that that have come across where I think
people don't understand that you do have
to talk about yourself to a certain
extent and I think people feel
uncomfortable about I think that's what
I one of the things I try to do when
when where I'm doing my networking
classes I try to do icebreakers so that
people get used to being asked about
themselves and about their projects
because maybe they're taught that well
you don't you should be talking about
yourself just be talking about your
project it's a combination we are not
only looking for a project we are
looking for somebody we want to be in
business with and that's what I'm trying
to get across is that it's a two-fold
thing and so when you build your network
of contacts
that is exactly what you should be doing
you should be talking about your
projects to these people you until your
your group but also letting them know a
little bit more about who you are as a
person these things stick in our mind
one guy came in and he had actually
gotten a couple of jobs you know doing
small little rewrites and he had done
some punch up stuff for comedies and I
remember he kept looking at his watch oh
you're having a meeting he he was
pitching a story to me he kept looking
at his watch and I finally just said do
you need to go somewhere do an
appointment and he just said I really
feel embarrassed but I'm really into
fantasy baseball our fantasy baseball
league I'm supposed to meet some friends
and and it had been he did a movie he
did a conversation with me and it was
unfortunately at the end of the day and
I was running late and so he was kind of
concerned about that but it didn't work
out but he did give me a good pitch in
terms of you know I but what was funny
is that one thing his honesty about
saying well you don't write I'm sorry
I'm just a big nerd about this fantasy
baseball thing and I that's stuck in me
I it was so funny six months later the
head of studio said you know what my
kids doing little again I want to talk
to you know I think we should do
something about Little League do you
know how fanatical people are and about
Little League and about baseball and
stuff like this and and so anyway it's
it was one of those things where he says
we need to do a project on this and we
need to find a writer so maybe we can if
we can talk to a bunch of writers about
this so guess whose name came
immediately I thought oh yes let's get
Kevin and so we did this thing where we
had some other some of the other execs
too had people that they had in mind him
to come in and we listened to about five
or six pitches
Kevin's was like head and shoulders
above all the rest because he was a
fanatic about baseball was just that one
little sentence that he gave me where
you're networking with people and you're
letting somebody know a little bit about
yourself and opening up and so that's
why I want to encourage
writers to do that I think it's
important that they open up about who
they are to
you